okay so I don't see anybody that's been
in on any of these entrepreneurship
kinds of sessions and discussions in the
past you have no so I'm at no risk of
repeating anything that you've all heard
at least from me so name it our topic is
kind of culture and you know how do you
build a culture and how do you think
about culture when you're building a
business I presume all of you are
building businesses have built
businesses have thought about building
businesses have watched others build
businesses so this is something that's
it's of interest or you wouldn't be here
today but what do you worry about you're
building a business what are your worry
beads what's the stuff you spend your
your time and thought well you thought
this was going to be a lecture
presentation I'm gonna make you work
yeah getting a great team together and
so you spent a lot of time sifting
sorting selecting interviewing hiring
training and I hope firing not that
that's fun or than anybody looks forward
to that but you better be firing
if you're building a great business what
other things do you worry about when
you're growing a business yeah in a
three-team an age so not only hiring but
it's keep getting on the same play book
in the same playbook yeah yeah math you
have enough money that's a big one
almost all entrepreneurs spent a whole
lot of their time thinking about you
know do I have enough cash other things
yeah
yeah because entrepreneurs are they feel
the pressure of it they're hard driving
they've got an idea or a concept or
something they want to get done
not everybody's bought into the same
level and so they want to push everybody
else on the on the team but they want to
push them so hard that they drive them
off they get them to go to a
competitor's startup something yeah
Carmen right so it's kind of a market
cons it yeah where are we in the mark in
the cycle of the market
what are competitors doing so how do we
think how do we think about that this is
one of my star students from way back he
knows all the answers so if we get stuck
in this turn fit turn to him yeah so
market issues anything else that you
really worry about when you're an
entrepreneur what do you lie awake at
night thinking about it
so we've got people we've got market
we've got capital yeah that which is
another form of thinking about the
market I always think about what's the
competitive response going to be to any
move I make a lot of times I'll see
something that's a real opportunity but
if I forget that there's other people in
the marketplace it's not you know making
one good move I've any of you been
watching curling I can't help it I mean
I wake up in the middle of night and so
curling is what's on this is like it's a
great sport I mean I'm not sure it's a
sport but it is fabulously they call it
chess on ice you know because I mean
it's really there's a lot of strategy
and everything and so you lie awake at
night you can watch curling or you think
about you know what what you should be
thinking about with your business so the
odds you won't like seeing this slide
but nine out of ten startups fail 75%
was VC funding failed to have an up
round and there very few that make it to
IPO or strategic sale so there's a lot
to worry about you know that says this
you know you're worried you're thinking
about these single that's not a it's not
unusual and there's a lot of reason
worried it's not to say that you don't
do it or there aren't some spectacular
successes and there a lot of them I know
in this room but a lot of people don't
don't pull this up very well so now when
you say okay we're here now here's a
bunch of entrepreneurs who've met at
Stanford and we're going to talk about
culture what the heck this culture have
to do with those things that you were
just worried about your worry beads
you're lying awake in it or any of you
lying awake at night thinking about
culture yeah
you are quite oh we have a team that
went into hibernation we ran short of
moving out short so looking back over
the experience I try to figure out what
kept the team going so little and yet
one of my team members
so I actually home in a graduate school
people sent them and I've come to the
conclusion release journaling how do you
connect out
so somehow you're saying that really
this this glue of culture that sort of
support is the net that people are
caught in and work with is really a
powerful way to keep people engaged and
particularly when you're doing these
entrepreneurial things that are risky
where nine out of ten fail where you
have money probably we have all these
other things culture can be a pretty
darn powerful tool and if you're in a
start-up you have one of the the unique
opportunities in life to build the
culture you want to have you know which
is most of the time you you join a
company and the cultures there and you
either become part of that culture you
influence it but if it's a very large
organization you don't influence it very
much or you adapt dramatically to that
and that that culture becomes kind of
ingrained in you or you leave you get
frustrated you have a clash karma right
that particular external culture and
that's where you're going to be driving
a business so yeah you need to think
really hard about whether the culture
that is the embodiment of your values in
the way you work and the way you want
your dealer really connects with the
marketplace and those that you're doing
because if there's a clash there the
odds are like kind of for an organ
rejection you know how hard it used to
be to get to transplant organs well in
some ways transplanting a culture into a
marketplace or environment that doesn't
want that culture you're going to have a
rejection of it so I would say for most
so I bought about a hundred companies
and started maybe six or seven and led a
number of so I've had a lot of
experience at failure and and watching
things get organized and disorganized in
whatever I would say that people don't
spend a whole lot of time thinking and
worry about culture culture they think
fact I was in one of these meetings two
or three years ago we were sort of
talking about it and that we got part of
the way nothing and a guy and I asked
the guy what do you have as a culture in
your company says we don't have a
culture we don't have a culture in our
company we don't need no stinkin culture
was basically and and I looked around
there were a bunch of knowing looks on
the faces of people and I said what are
you smiling about in the woman that I
called I said he has a culture he really
has a culture we don't need no stinkin
culture you've got one let me tell you
you've got a powerful culture already so
but not a lot of people think about it
intentionally
you're not intentional about the culture
they just say I am Who I am like it or
leave it you know this is who I am I do
things a certain way adapt I'm the
entrepreneur I've got the idea I raise
the capital you better fit so that's how
a lot of people think about culture
we're going to talk today about how you
can be more intentional about it yeah
yeah so I don't want to really get into
because you can talk about mission
vision values and then it's kind of
translate we'll talk about that a little
bit but you're absolutely right your
culture is a very much a part of that
whole thing it really connects tightly
but it's easy to get lost in
definitional no-man's land with those
things so what I really wanted to speak
it kind of a content a conceptual level
and really get the idea of you know what
is a culture really and how do you
influence it how do you change it how do
you develop it intentionally so today
we've got a keynote speaker here and I
was interested to read this quote so
here's the founder of chairman and CEO
of Four Seasons resorts and he gives his
reason for success what so is this a
culture statement is this a an
assessment of culture what how does this
kind of a statement connect with the
idea of a culture is there our culture
at four seasons
the
derives from this yep yes so the way I
can see this culture is basically
allowing everybody to accomplish the
same every mine where everybody connects
with a certain value and behaves a
certain way that we're saying okay and
what would you say in a word without
saying this but what would you say would
be the characteristics of this culture
if this were true service caring about
other people it's really being other
focus caring about other people now what
happens if this guy I've never met him I
assume he's terrific but what if he says
this is our culture and then he get to
the office and he barks at his assistant
and he throws his briefcase across the
room when something bad happens and you
know chews out the manager of the hotel
what happens what is the culture then
well I think it's tyrannical but I
actually think it's even more cynical
than it would be if he were just to not
have made this statement you know the
fact that you make a statement say this
is the secret of our success this is our
secret sauce this is who we are these
are our values this is what we're about
you by gosh better live those values or
you're going to develop a cynical
culture and you're going to have a
culture where everybody is a cynic and a
critic and holds back and is weary and
reads the tea leaves of what you say so
anytime you get out there so one of the
ideas about building cultures think
carefully about the statements you make
about your culture because you will be
held accountable to those people really
pay a lot of attention to these
expressions of values and we'll see why
in a little bit uh so early stage
business you know I think everybody now
I don't know if anybody willing to say
this but any of you ever worry about
failure this is Stanford so nobody ever
worries about it I've worried about
failure MA
and it's kind of what I think about
every morning how am I going to fail the
day you know it's dandy Grove wrote this
big only the paranoid survive that's
kind of how I've been I've just been
worried all the time I got run into all
so people think about failure you know a
lot of successful people think a whole
lot about failure and they're trying to
keep from failing well if you read these
things you know it's really kind of this
is kind of a compilation of surveys and
studies of entrepreneurs and basically
they can boil down to these three things
where just culture fit in there so it
would sound like from reading that you
can have a bad culture a really stinking
culture and still not worry about
failure or just culture fit in there
some how or should there be other should
there be other things to think about
well this is what people traditionally
think about in entrepreneurship courses
and startup courses they say man there's
a lot of uncertainty when you start a
business there's a lot of scarcity of
people capital you know ideas probably
everything and there's and we're just
involved in chain everything's dynamic
it's so dynamic so those are the three
characteristics well so why worry about
this culture thing over here when you've
got we got the the tectonic plates are
moving you know you're standing there
trying to keep your balance and here
you've got this clown here saying you
ought to think about culture you know
culture is race it well that there's
another study that I think you'll find
well here's the this is the seven Habits
of Highly Effective entrepreneurs this
is what you if you really talk to to
most entrepreneurs say well what really
are your valley what do you think about
but I would submit to you that these are
the most profound values that
entrepreneurs have is don't run out of
liquidity you know make sure you've got
enough capital you know to keep going
but here's the other one that I wanted
to get to and that is this idea of
culture so each a cadiz who is a
professor at UCLA did a study of what he
called corporate life cycles and it was
sort of the thesis was every business
fails you know there are no business
East India Trading company's the oldest
the world it goes back to the sixteenth
century or something like that but other
than that you can pretty much go the the
Fortune 100 companies in 1900 only three
still exist today to give you an idea of
the half-life of companies it's just not
all that long so the question is when do
they fail well he's he sort of said here
are the thing so they go through these
stages you know and this is kind of the
stage you're in somewhere in here is
where entrepreneurs are operating this
is the most exciting time for a company
but look over here at the most common
causes for failure at those stages well
the first one is the one you'd expect
don't run out of cash you know be well
capitalized so liquidity so the second
one is this one that you are quick to
bring up all three or four of you back
up there we're saying boy it's hiring
people it's getting good people it's
like you were saying keeping them on the
team keeping them motivated you know
getting that team together that's the
second but look here number three is the
culture this issue of values and norms
is the reason that companies fails they
don't get synched up on that and then
the other thing dealing with the founder
is often a problem that makes it make
some of you really spooked you know is
that as often a reason that startups
fail is because the founder either
doesn't leave doesn't get out the right
time doesn't bring his replacement in
does it change does take on the sales
role or something else and insists on
remaining the founder and doing the CEO
kind of role so that's that's another
reason and there's a final one is what's
called adjusting the offering which
means that was a study done at Harvard
Business School I think about 10 or 12
years ago where they measured what
percentage of the business plans that
were submitted actually turned into
businesses and then of those which ones
were the same business coming out as
they were going in so the business plan
described what the actual business was
and it turns out that 97% of
them either you know didn't turn into
that visit or they morphed they
significantly morphed so only three
percent so if you don't morph the
business so morphing your business is
part of your life if you're an
entrepreneur so that would say something
to you about the kind of culture you
want to have if these are our common
causes for failure you're going to want
a culture that takes these into account
and deals effectively with with them
they're going to be flexible dynamic see
organic things as non-threatening
embrace change you know do all kinds of
things and so that becomes an a really
important value in an entrepreneurial
enterprise so I would say that the
eighth habit which is really the second
habit you know make sure you got
liquidity that's the first seven things
but then make sure you get a culture
that is sustainable and that really
promotes your primary objective so we're
going to talk some about how you I do
that white culture let's start here with
we'll just make some lists here how many
of you have been part of a great culture
just by show of hands it's about half
how many of you have been part of a
terrible culture about the same number
how many of you have been part of but
I've experienced both about the same
number so we know something about at
least we have an idea so let's let's
give some examples of great cultures and
what we may just list a half a dozen
companies here and then what are the
descriptors what about it made them
terrific and then let's do the same
thing on the other side and see if there
any any patterns here yeah okay
other examples yeah which i think is
pretty much that same idea when you say
yeah yeah insurance coming in San
Antonio
I don't know that one American
now you may feel like I'm forcing this a
little bit here but and I probably am
but really if you if you sift through
and think through these things it is
really a congruent with stated value
there's a strong set of values that are
thought through and expressed their
lived from the top they're enforced
throughout the organization people
really live the values so that's that's
an interesting thing because now let's
let's go to terrible cultures and see
they might just be the flip side of this
they say one thing and they do another
but then we may see some other patterns
here that's enough we've kind of made
the point on this what about terrible
cultures if anybody dares say
what would you say about it okay yeah
audax
aid help me again what were the
manifestation changing yeah yep
any others yeah son financial
so anybody see a pattern here or
anything that you could can you describe
what goes on with these that just
alienate us is that your hand up or
you're just you have to be really
careful with me if you if you scratch
your mouth like that you get a cold call
Vivian
okay what Valek I don't know them
so there's a non-alignment with people I
mean if you're really doing it I mean
let's try to summarize if you could just
take a snapshot of that and think
through what is it that goes wrong what
where's the illness in these kinds of
organ in these kinds of cultures and
what does it stem from because they
didn't start out and say let's have a
really crappy culture you know I know
how we can offend all these people let's
drive off the best people I know I've
got an idea
yeah well I think there's see any one
thing yeah so I mean there is something
there about this alignment you know who
you hire if you bring in a lot of people
who just don't fit with that culture you
know who is it
the Yankees used to fight like cats and
dogs you know they didn't get along but
they were the best in the world they did
have kind of a of a bad-boy culture you
know that allowed them to win so that
they fit with that there's a bunch of
sports teams you know where they haven't
necessarily had the best you know
culture in the locker room but they win
and so they have a winning culture and
kind of a chip on their shoulder
attitude and it tends to work for ya
if part of it is whether I'm going to
what motivates people
whether it's some objective goal that
truly care about our fire fight or does
the lacking masses of the corporation
create some poems or that motivation in
some other way yep so one of the things
I often expect I'm not sure I can apply
it to this list precisely but often
there's politics you know and what do
politics mean in an organization that
people don't go out and get elected but
when you think about a heavily political
organization how would you describe
that's a really political place what
does that mean they pay attention to
who's in power they are respecters of
persons and of title and of hierarchy
they check out where you are in the list
and they treat you well depending on
where you are in the pecking order if
you're the if you're the receptionist
you're dog meat nobody listens to you if
you're the assistant to somebody nobody
pays any attention to you can't have a
good idea healthy culture is the best
idea tends to win it's not where a
person that they're not political so
there's a there's a huge element of
politics usually in these terrible
cultures it's hard to say a whole
industry I mean I remember so I had a
fair amount of experience with the
Salomon Brothers and Goldman Sachs I'll
tell you a quick story and then we'll
move on but I remember going into
Salomon Brothers and I was trying to
rage a 500 million dollar facility this
is a big facility in those days big
today I think but it was huge in those
days so was a big piece of business for
them and so I got in there I went alone
to New York and they had ten bankers
sitting around the table and about
halfway and they were all vying for air
space they were talking over each other
they were I mean and I just I gave him
my name and that was it and I didn't get
one more word in and then all of a
sudden John good friend who was the
former managing partner Salomon Brothers
walked in and it escalated I mean if I
thought it was chaotic before as soon as
good friend and entered the room
everybody was trying to out talk and
outsell
out impress each other so it's very much
you know a star system and it was the it
was the hungriest bear that got all the
food that saw my brothers so I left
Salomon Brothers I walked across the
street just Goldman Sachs and there
could not have been a more different
environment it was team it was
showcasing into it they list it first of
all they listened to me they said Joel
what are you here for what would you
like what would be the perfect outcome
for you how would you think about this
that the other and I felt really
listened to and then they and it was an
exchange so even in those kinds of
things where you may have some industry
cultures that you can characterize a
little bit but even in those there's a
broad range and I would say there's
anybody in here ever worked for Salomon
Brothers it was it was an unbelievably
miserable place I think I think you know
it had anybody it would have been over
on this list it was a very very tough
place to survive and enjoy life so okay
well that'll give you a little bit to go
on here now I'm going to ask you about
this what if what if I said here are the
six words that describe it this is by
the way the Speaker of the keynote
speaker at one of these conferences came
and gave a talk and I asked a similar
clip we had the this kind of
get-together after his speech and I said
let's describe his culture
what was his culture like and these were
the six words that came out is this a
great culture would you like to work for
that if I told you this is all you can
know about this you want to take the
guys standing out there do you want to
go take the job that this really
accurately captures this was kind of the
consensus would you like that or not
your establishment young star so this
issue of fit fitting the culture to the
people in to the circumstances the
community right is a really important
one to think through if I told you so
I'm the chairman of an airline called
JetBlue if I told you these are are
about this is the essence of our culture
how would you feel know if I just taking
this up please understand get this on
tape clearly I'm not saying this are
jetblue's values now but if I did tell
you that these are the values of our
airline what would you say
chaotic is not what we want yeah you
don't want chaotic in that but if you're
a software company if you're cutting
edge taking you kind of want this
chaotic you know I mean what these
creative people who can live with chaos
the marketplace is essentially chaos so
this could be extend this was an
extraordinarily successful tech firm
here in the valley and these were very
attractive elements of the culture the
first one that you have down for JetBlue
our first value is safety you know and
we pay all kinds of attention and spend
all kinds of time and money and safety
that's our number-one value and that's
the essence of our culture in fact we
print on on the back of these cards what
our five values are the first one listed
at the top is safety and big bold
letters so everybody all 12,000
employees wear safety on their chests
every day yeah um so
we need some of these yeah so it's a
morphing a culture you know how we
talked about morphing a product and a
service that is essential morphing a
culture is also essential how do you
morph a culture what's the most powerful
way to morph a culture
well example is a really critical thing
but but when you have so we've got
12,000 employees now how do you give
that example you can influence 12,000
employees yeah stories are one powerful
way how you behave
you know never violating a certain set
of values those are two powerful ways I
think there's one that's even more
potent yeah I think hiring and firing
there is nothing as powerful as who do
you bring on the boat and how do they
progress and how are they promoted and
who do you let go I mean you say worlds
with every one of those key personnel
moves you morph the culture and so
that's really I think a very powerful
way to do that so I want you to think
about your own culture I'm gonna give
you an exercise here in a minute but
what do you think about wherever you are
even if you're a student you're here at
Stanford and you know what's the culture
of your dorm or your set of friends or
whatever so think about whatever your
Miglia is I want you to think about the
culture almost interim and I want you to
think about it in six words and to get
you started on that I'm going to give
you a six word short story that Ernest
Hemingway wrote for sale baby shoes
never worn you know and as a father of
seven kids I got choked up when I first
read that I mean I was moved by that
story I could write a I mean this was a
story to me there was a fellow that I
knew who is an Academy award-winning
filmmaker who bought the rights to the
Norman Rockwell paintings anybody old
enough any you know Norman Rockwell you
know Norman Rockwell the young people
may not know
is a very famous American illustrator
who painted these pictures of Americana
just these quintessential scenes from
American life and he bought the the
rights to these posters and said I'm
going to make a film for each of these
so that really the the poster is the
poster and now I'm going to create the
story behind it and the poster will
become the advertising the things so in
a sense capturing with a picture the
essence of a whole story so here's a
story for you
and I want you to start thinking about
your own culture in this book while
you're doing that I'm going to give you
some other examples this is actually a
number of people do this now for fun
there's actually a kind of a whole
effort here to write six word short
stories so here's some I don't think any
of us is powerful is Ernest Hemingway's
but I can I can see I know some of these
people
so you got those and everybody through
those looks like here's the next set and
then we'll move on I'm going to
so there's kind of whole stories there
so this is a little bit different drill
but you can see the power of very few
words in capturing the essence of
someone's life or of a story or whatever
so I want you now to pair up as best you
can
and write your six word value state your
six where what are the six words that
capture whatever your culture is
presently so it no more than three in a
group but pair up with somebody who's
close to you and and tell it in a way
that each of you can capture the others
when you pick that you pick the culture
you want to talk about but pick a
culture that you live in and describe it
in six words capture your culture in six
words how many of you felt like you were
able to describe your own whatever
culture you decide to scribe in six
words and felt happy with it how many of
you were able to describe whatever
culture you was you're describing in six
words and felt really pretty happy that
you'd captured the essence of the
culture so maybe a third of you how many
of you who listened to that the others
felt like I get it I understand their
culture I really so it's about the same
number felt that way what was the
limited what kept the rest of you from
getting there
yeah personally the conflict between
what I think the stated culture is or
what it ideally would be and then how it
falls slightly shorter we've been
looking at good cultures those were bad
I think most cultures probably have a
little bit of both so Kent is that that
makes it harder to describe so here's
what I do and we'll get into this in a
couple of minutes I use a kind of a
mapping tool that I think about to me
facts are stubborn things it was
President John Adams who first said that
facts are stubborn things find out the
facts what is the truth
if the stated culture is one thing and
the real culture the normative culture
the informal culture is another you have
a certain degree of cynicism in those
cultures so one of the descriptors of
that kind of a culture would be it's a
cynical political culture as much as we
want it to be this other it really isn't
so I think what you want to do on these
countries is really try to capture
reality it's the starting point if you
want to build a great culture start with
reality assess things honestly as to
where they are not what you wish they
were not how you wish you were you know
because most of the time you do want to
tweak and change that you really want to
not be exactly what you are naturally
you know build something great I find
that I have to really strive for
something better than I really am
naturally so I think it's the same thing
in businesses and cultures
I don't Photoshop I really don't and you
know what happens is people trust me
more if I really say our culture now I
have to believe that this is one of the
words that I would use for the cultures
I want is it it's transparent and so if
I really believe that it's a really
transparent and I give you photoshopped
pictures of everything you're going to
say that stinker he says that but that's
not really IBA and they're going to
start conclude they're going to start me
migrating over to the bad culture side
of the board so you really want to think
about what are these words but for me
transparency is one of the things that I
like admire my trust level goes up with
transparent people I want to be part of
something we're really dealing with the
real facts and so I will not even if the
news is bad I believe in giving it
unvarnished to people I think people are
smart they figure it out anyway and just
tell them say this is the this is the
problem we face this is the challenge
we're going to have a tough a tough year
we're gonna have to cut back on cuz this
is going to be and you may find some
pushback on some of these things you can
create some problems for yourself do
that I find that over and this is a 63
year old talking here I understand that
and I've made mistakes and whatever but
over time over a long lifetime things I
have found that complete transparency
open Ness increases trust high trust
builds better cultures more flexibility
more adaptiveness to the marketplace so
it's just one of the rules for me as
painful as it is sometimes now I'm not
recommending it to you I'm just saying
if you want to be if that's a value to
you if you want to create that in your
culture it's really up to you to behave
that way with some people like to share
what some of the words are just shout
them out I won't write them down but
let's just what are some of the words
that came out of this
Consensus shiny objects what does shiny
objects mean okay so this is a newness
culture I'm with you okay okay so you
can tell what business she's in she
takes old homes important old homes and
restores them to original view so she's
all about that now that doesn't say a
whole lot about her culture does it it
says a little bit about values and what
she does but you have a night is this
her organization political is she a very
top-down manager is that the best idea
wins I mean I don't know all those thing
them I'm not asking you to answer it
either but when you think about culture
think a lot about process about how
people so I was in a company one time
that that said this is actually a large
real estate development company called
the Trammell Crowe company if any of you
know real estate it was the largest
private real estate developer in the
world and we said we're about being
profitable we're about being great
partners and we're about being
profitable when I came in as the
managing partner we were losing you know
we're starting to an apt billion dollars
worth of new development every year and
we were losing about twenty five million
dollars a year on it you know in terms
of the fee income side of it we were
trying to make it all up in appreciation
and in growth as it turns out we had
lots of words around partnership and
profits and you know shared the set of
the other but we were a fast growth
company our value was fast growth
biggest the incentives were to go out
and develop new space that the
celebrations were all around the person
who built the biggest thing or at least
the most square feet everything was
about size and speed and growth we were
a grow fast culture everything in that
culture was about
grow fast so I think that it's kind of
how our decisions made what is this
really about yours is about shiny object
I mean we love innovation we love the
new idea the new thing is really what
gets people going and we don't want to
build systems to support the old idea
really scrub it or where people get
bored with that so that's an interesting
thing in a culture you want to keep that
you want to change it you want to morph
it do you need to when will you need to
what kinds of people you need to bring
so there's all those kinds of issues
around any other would like to share
yeah service care quality okay so
there's a hotel company that I won't
it'll go nameless but one of my friends
was the the chairman of it and he asked
it's not the four seasons
he asked the CEO the kinds of people
that they hire and he said we hire
people who are incredibly friendly and
he said well I've got a young student
from a well-known school Ivy League
she's just a wonderful person okay how
about if we send her to and I won't tell
you the city either to the interview and
she went through these interviews they
were fine interviews you know people
liked her she had the pedigree she's a
perfectly good employee and so my friend
called up this Chairman and said so how
did it all go it was wonderful young
woman did you hire no we didn't we said
well why in the world didn't you hire
she's well would you say she's
incredibly friendly she's friendly but
was she incredibly friendly well no she
wasn't really incredibly well so when we
decided that she wasn't incredibly
friendly we didn't hire her we didn't
violate that cultural norm because we're
building an incredibly friendly company
now with that you can probably narrow it
down to a couple of hotels and I think
one airline I hope
let's see what I do with this thing so
this should be come an easy thing for
you to do I would say that the powerful
cultures of the world can be described
in very few numbers of words and you
really say what am I about what matters
in the marketplace what matters to me
and my values how do I transmit those
and really get it down so that it is and
I would encourage you Carmen to think
more in terms of how do we press well
you know how do we make decisions what
works any or not what do we do how do we
go about it is the essence of culture so
here's a map for analyzing thinking
about building culture Dave will
recognize this maybe nobody else will
but this is adapted from Marvin Bauer
who's one of my heroes he was actually
the founder of the jonesed a law firm
which is I think the second or third
largest law firm in the United States
and a founder of McKinsey so this is a
pretty incredible guy and he wrote a
book called the will to manage which if
you tried to get it today it would cost
you 500 bucks on Amazon there are just
so few copies of it but this and it's
and you would like it's anachronistic
the examples are from back in the 40s
and 50s and wetter so I'm not telling
you to go out and spend 500 bucks on
this book you won't like but there are
some really powerful kind of eternal
ideas he uses a little different words
but this is my map this is my
interpretation of what Marvin Bower say
that is that powerful cultures align
from top to bottom so you get all the
way down to the metrics the things that
you're measuring you're reporting on
paying people on these controls are
completely in sync with the values of
the organization there is no light
between the one leads to the other to
the other to the other so you avoid this
notion of cynicism but we sought if they
don't live their values well this is a
this is a map if you really think
through each of these not will spend the
last 20 minutes kind of examining this
if you really get consistent on that the
odds of building a powerful sustaining
culture
that get you to a new place are really
quite high so we'll start with values
yeah this is probably applicable that
unless you get these in alignment you
don't really have a successful coming
here it's not just a culture and I
presume your premise is that without the
culture we don't really have a
successful company but this strikes me
is at the very heart of building real
successful I totally agree with you I
think that's the fundamental map but I
think it starts with because culture is
so tied to the top to the values and
objectives you know if you get that
wrong or don't get that clear the odds
of radiating all the way through the
order to have a successful powerful
organization are minimal so that's a
good clarification this is a map for a
whole company really understanding and I
go into companies and just say are these
guys likely to be successful or not and
I look and if I see a lot of daylight
between these things if I see like my
old days where we said we're about one
thing but all the incentives were for
every we measured was growth I can say
these guys are really quite me they're
nice guys they smile a lot they look at
but they're not really living what they
say they're about so I think you're
right that's a great comment yeah
yeah I think that probably is a meta
concept you know if you really say what
is our mission and our vision and you
know what's the tart who were serving
whom with what you know in what unique
way now what are our values what our
objective and I think you kind of work
your way down there so I think there's
kind of a meta layer here that I think
you have to have to get in busy but so
so here's some of the points that I
would make on that in terms of values
where you start thinking about values
people have strong views about values
they hold their values dear sometimes
close to the vest but you can always
tell if I were to spend a day or two
with any of you I would know what your
values are because values are where you
spend your time your money and your mind
chair which is what you think about and
talk about it's what you say to yourself
when you're showering you know it's what
so really your values are deeply deeply
embedded and you and they are observable
you can see a person's vote and so when
people say their values are one thing
and then they behave another way and I
see this all the time with you is that
I'm really committed to this that and
the other and then they spend all day
watching soap operas I'm making that up
but all right because I have a good
friend who's the chairman of the charter
of associates a big think-tank in in
Boston and he asks me so what happened
on Days of Our Lives yesterday you know
is it like no but so I mean you really
have to your behaviors get really good
so I I pay a whole lot of attention to
where people spend time money and mind
share those are their values and then
the second thing is that they're not
virtues a lot of times people think
virtues are values integrity
forthrightness you know all these things
that sound high-minded but really your
values if you really boil it down it's
where you spend it's Who I am so I have
a funny story here at least settings
when I've I've made the this statement
to a number of classes for years and
years now that the most valley the most
important value statement of an organ is
is its budget because that's where
you're saying here's we're going to
spend our money we're going to spend
training here's what we're going to do
so the budget is the most valuable is
the most potent value statement in an
organization so I have a kid who went to
school here at Stanford he applied to
both Harvard and Stanford Business
School's he ended up getting into both
of them and he decided to go to Harvard
Business School I said what are you
thinking I went there this is the better
business school said dad I can't go
there because you're there you know I
just don't want to be where you know
you're there so I felt kind of bad about
that and then about a year or so into it
he says dad I just was in my strategy
class and somebody said values are are
the most important value statement of an
organization is the budget and and one
of the students said that's a really
important idea and the professor said
yeah there's a guy out at Stanford who's
been saying that they asked for the name
he said his name is Joel Peterson and my
scientists but you know we couldn't
believe it but I really I believe this
forever
that you really really want to
understand the value really want to get
to the core of culture look at where
people spend their money their time in
their mind share those are the values
and then cynicism develops around saying
something's your value and then behaving
in a way that your time money and mine
share is somewhere else so
they don't train they don't keep the
ones that they've got they don't treat
them right they take advantage of them
they don't celebrate their success they
don't they don't do any of those they
just say it words are cheap and words
create cynicism
I am very cautious about what I say I
try to behave my partner one time he
says you can't talk your way out of
problems you behaved your way into and
by the same token you can't create a
culture with words that you've behaved
your way out of you have to behave your
way into a culture you have to hire
people who behave it and make darn sure
you don't put words around something
that isn't real or you will have one of
these cynical cultures that will drive
up all your best people you'll lock in
the deadwood and you'll stagnate so here
are some of the value conflicts it's not
easy to just to answer these you know
because every organization says man and
I told you the one that we had was a
growth or profits those are in in
opposition in many phases of the market
many many times you find then we can
either take advantage of growth or we
can be profitable we can't do both at
the same time so there's a value
judgment there so in every one of these
you know I sort between it all the time
with customers shareholders and
employees you know when you have a have
an airline you have lots of employees
you have lots and lots of customers and
you have shareholders who are not making
much of a return on their investment and
so you have to balance all those and
they all want more of it so what is your
what's your priority how do you behave
there that's a culture so you can see
that where these conflicts are is where
you really deliver the message on what
your values are conflict is an
opportunity to deliver powerful messages
yeah
right I think it is a little bit
different I would say that shareholders
I put last you know most boards of
directors so we work for the
shareholders that's our job you know we
look out for my view is that will take
care of itself it's a little bit like I
don't know if you heard the story you
know who Pablo Casals is the great
cellist
he was the last generations yo-yo ma and
the example is public assaults playing
in Carnegie Hall and you go up to me say
Pablo that was fabulous what what are
you doing here at Carnegie Hall and if
he answered I'm making a hundred
thousand bucks you'd say mmm you know
he's that's a that's a kind of a
surprising well my same view is with
shareholders you what are we doing here
we're making money for our share home no
we're serving customers and so I try to
keep my eye on what we call crew members
and employees and and customers and I
I've a slight eye so I keep them right
neck and neck yeah there i I think I
probably in the end crown the customer
I think customer if you can have a
customer service organization above all
I would probably opt for that but I
think the way that you get there is by
celebrating crew members most of the
time sometimes you get crew members who
ask too much you put themselves first
who aren't in that and you probably need
to fire them then but if you're in
certain industries that's hard to do
long answer but uh so think about these
values come these are these are moments
and opportunities for cultural
development conflict is great there's a
guy named I think it's Patrick Lencioni
who wrote a short book on meetings they
said you know if you want to have a
great meeting if you want to run great
meetings make sure there's conflict this
is just like a movie or a book they're
only interesting if there's conflict you
know if they're different
points of view that can be re so make
sure there's come so I regard conflict
and differences of opinion as a cell to
me it's a high-value thing it would be
one of my words is celebrate conflict
welcomed conflict you know it be a
culture that I love is one where people
can take off posing points of view argue
them and then ultimately you wrestle
them to the ground and yet and the best
idea wins then you move forward you all
support it so that to me is kind of a
cultural thing but conflict to me is
something that will really help you sort
through that don't be afraid of it lots
of people are afraid of conflict and I
would say if you want to have a great
culture embrace it look for it celebrate
it and then be thoughtful and I you so
then the next thing is your values
should drive you to objective we're
going to kind of blast through this
pretty quickly I just want to give you
this map with enough flesh on the bones
that it'll mean something to you
I think this is the most powerful way
for an entrepreneur to lead values
you've written down in six words you
kind of know in your mind you'll hire
and fire to get there you know how will
you spend your money time and mind
Cheryl today so that's kind of the
values drill setting correct objectives
is the most powerful lever
you've got they just can't be
inconsistent with your values so you
can't say you know our values are
serving mankind or making the world a
better place and get it and we really
want to make big bucks on illegal drugs
that's kind of our business model is
just we really want to knock it out of
the park with illegal drug so you got to
have consistency there so objectives I
would say the other thing to think about
this is I find that people will not
compromise values they'll easily
compromise controls or metrics or
measurements so as you move down the
list you have lots more of these you
have fewer and fewer as you go up and
people will compromise easily these they
will never compromise if you have a
conflict over values my view is separate
don't try to sort it out you know gets
you have to have people with the same
values at the top leading it developing
the culture so just separate don't fight
you just go your own way there's not one
value system for everyone in every
market and every
every era separate so setting objectives
so I wanted to give you a couple of
examples here of great objectives this
is the one that Pepsi had for 30 years
beat coke and in 2006 they beat coke so
that's the problem you know you had this
objective it's through the entire
organization you've achieved it what do
you do
yet now what exactly well you've got to
come up with a new objective that's as
inspiring so yeah here's Indra Nooyi
new objective is we want to be known as
the way you do business globally set the
standard so it's high-minded and she's
developed some specific measures around
that since then but that's a pretty
pretty good of Jake here's another
famous one that is even a better one
land a man on the moon and bring him
home safely within the decade
that's JFK it's measurable it's
inspiring it's aspirational it's
memorable it's all these kinds of things
so think about if you want to have a
great culture if you want to have clear
values you've got to set a clear simple
understandable easily communicated
objective that people can remember
here's another one who's this Bill Gates
it sounded ridiculous
I remember I remember my brothers who
are 10 years young and me bringing home
computer said this is a really cool
thing you can do pong on it and you can
run spreadsheets and so it was calling
it was that see prompt they need anybody
remember say wow it was prove enough
that this will never work
you know nobody will ever do this and
I'll be darned how wrong I was so I
don't know if we go in on every desktop
but there's a big idea memorable one you
can visualize it and they behave
consistently with that objective here's
the last one that I want to tell you
this story on victory I think and Dave
knows this my view is winning is the
most powerful thing you can ever do to
create it because you can create a
winning culture people love to win they
just love it and you can actually create
winning while you're losing that's one
of the more challenging things I've had
to turn around some organization
I'm such a big believer in people
winning and having a great culture but
what you do is you say we lost less
money last month than the month before
you know and we did this and we have
these objectives and we achieved them
you celebrate wherever you are moving in
the right direction
so victory and this is the one that
inspires me is this is a picture of
Winston Churchill leaving number 10
Downing Street on May 10th May 13th
the Germans had crossed the Meuse river
on the 10th and so the weekend had gone
by this is a Monday he's with Clement
Attlee and Neville Chamberlain Neville
Chamberlain of the fame of we've now
brought peace in our time he'd appeased
Hitler he thought and they went down to
Parliament to speak and Chamberlain
received a warm welcome and gave a long
speech and Winston Churchill got up and
gave a 1-page speech and it was received
you know not very warmly and within that
Beach's 1:43 word paragraph that is the
following this is the famous blood toil
tears and sweat speech like you take a
second to read it
what do you think Churchill's objective
was is there any doubt I mean there's no
doubt as clearly remember all the
pictures of Churchill World War two what
was he holding up V for victory he was
all about you know and every speech he
gave everything that he did was about
that so a memorable attainable but
stretch objective that's consistent with
your values is a really powerful way to
start to create a great culture we've
only got a couple minutes so let's see
if there's anything here I wanted to
lead us through I guess the point of
this is to say that as the entrepreneur
as the founder as the people who are
trying to move things for you are really
responsible for setting values and
letting people go who don't and making
sure you hire people that share those
values and for setting the good clear
memorable aspirational achievable
objectives so that's your job the middle
manager the people you bring in to sort
of make things happen and measure things
and whatever they're really responsible
for tactics and controls in between
though is this place where you cross
which is called strategy and that's
where you get together and you really
create great cultures in strategy
development so here's how I look at this
particular map when I superimpose that
on I say you know why top management
then that probably gets to your mission
vision is kind of up in in that section
so why what's our goal what are we going
to do what are we going to do to attack
the market and then down into when how
who where all those kinds of issues and
then how do we measure it so that map if
that map is tight crisp understood
you're going to begin to develop a great
culture there's a we do surveys so I'm
on the board a company called Franklin
Covey and we do kind of various things
to help organizations achieve objectives
one of the things we do is is
goal assessment survey so we'll go into
an organization and ask everybody and
we've done this for all the fortune 500
companies we probably have a hundred
thousand of these surveys out there with
people and we ask people to name their
companies top three objectives you know
what percentage of people can list the
top three objectives of their
organization would you guess no it's
better than that come on it's 19% so
less than one person in five can say
here's what we're going to well if it's
less than wonderful how many of them do
you think have what I call a line of
sight who know when they walk in the
office this is what I'm - I'm not today
I'm not reconciling bank statement I am
helping us collect receivables so that
we can do this so that we can achieve
these objectives this month everybody
knows what their job is and how it helps
us do that not very many so that tells
you a lot of organizations really don't
have these powerful cultures where
everyone is aligned
everyone knows because they don't have
transparency people don't behave
consistently with what they say they
don't hire in fire they'll let value
conflicts fester rather than make the
changes they won't be intentional about
the culture and it's really one of the
reasons that businesses fail is because
they're not intentional of culture so
I'm not going to take you through these
but just to take you know a couple more
seconds on this because I think these
are there there are several cultures
that have been studied for why they work
and have worked the HP one is one that's
been studied forever respect for others
sense of community hard work
here's IBM respect the rights of each
individual best customer service in the
world all tasks in a superior way
Walmart respect the individuals service
to customers strive for excellence what
would you say about those you look at
them they're all the same aren't they I
mean really if you look at respect
brothers customer service and excellence
of execution why not just copy those
okay here's our culture we just copied
these successful organization now we've
got this culture well the trick is it
gets down to the execution so
you know strategy has to ultimately
devolve into work and that's really
where the rubber meets the road and we
don't have time I wish we had another
hour together but I was going to show
you Sam's ten rules you can probably
look this up online but look for Sam
Waltons ten rules look for how look for
the sundown rule the Walmart chair the
ten-foot rule every day low prices in
the Saturday morning celebration I mean
these are the stuff of creating a great
culture that's tied all the way back up
to the values of Walmart so it's not
just these big highfalutin ideas it's
they have operationalized all these
things they have made it real in the
lives of every employee we look forward
to who know how it can I so with
alignment you get high trust
organizations high trust organizations
can survive down times can survive times
like we're in today and by the way it
can be a micro event can be within your
industry can be within your geography or
you can have a whole industry meltdown
its toughest if it's the former - its
easiest when you have everything melting
down because every said well shoot I
don't have a bunch of options I'll just
stay with this but they're not happy
campers if you've develop a high trust
organization you can have your
organization suffer and you can still
keep people together and chart a new
course so with that sorry I kept you
over one minute have a great day today
Thanks